they call themselves the bad batch
The republic will be reorganized into the first Galactic Empire!
that was quite an impressive display
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new star wars trailer for the bad batch
i'll explain how this crosses over with the events
of the mandalorian in present day what's going on
with the other characters like obi-wan kenobi
what's happening with grogu during this period
what's happening with ahsoka and all the other
characters too if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos the
mandalorian season 2 finale is going to be
happening literally in a day as i'm posting
this video so there'll be a whole bunch of
stuff happening for that as well as all the other
star wars and marvel stuff that happened in the
past week a lot of you have also been asking me to
do a timeline video because there are so many star
wars series that they just announced especially
the live-action star wars series so i'll explain
what the timeline is starting with this series
but if you have no idea who the bad batch is
and you didn't watch the clone wars season
seven episodes the dave filoni did this
past year i did a couple videos for that
so i'll link those in the description
the bad batch is basically a group of
defective genetically abnormal clones
that wound up becoming clone force 99 they
call them the bad batch because they don't
look like all the other clones but their genetic
differences give them a bunch of special abilities
so it's hunter the leader he's the one with
the voice over at the beginning of the trailer
wrecker crosshair tech and then echo the cyborg
the other clone joined them at the end of the
clone wars episodes after they rescued him but
the whole thing with this series is that it picks
up immediately after revenge of the sith and
they're having to deal with emperor palpatine's
new regime and the way the empire people like
grand moff tarkin who's newly promoted to grand
moff he was just moff tarkin during the clone
wars the way that they're using them as their
new storm troopers going around subjugating
the rest of the galaxy bringing them in line
with the emperor's new wishes it's still kind of
a transition phase from clones to stormtroopers
like they still have the clone armor but it's
all white now like the classic stormtroopers
the armor itself won't change for a couple more
years and if you watch the clone wars finale it
explains how ahsoka goes into hiding leaving her
last lightsaber that anakin skywalker had given
her before he became darth vader only there's a
time jump when darth vader shows up it's several
years later and they fully transitioned to the new
imperial classic armor from the original trilogy
so the bad batch series sort of takes place in
between those events and i'll talk about the other
series in a second too this is also the period
where darth vader and the inquisitors has started
to hunt all the jedi going around so for instance
the events of jedi fall in order sort of cover
that vader going around hunting down the remaining
jedi when they start popping up all that stuff had
been happening for the past couple of years when
that picks up so this will cover some of that
one of the places that they go back to during
the trailer is the cloning facility of camino
obviously because the clones are still very much
alive during this period they haven't died off yet
when the empire was born at the end of revenge of
the sith the emperor publicly stated that he shut
down the kamino facility but secretly we know
that's not the case he just started conducting
his cloning experiments in secret to learn how
to clone himself and since a lot of that is
happening on the mandalorian now i'll talk about
grogu and moff giddy and the other characters and
what's happening with them during the events of
this series but one of the other big mandalorian
crossover characters is a much younger version
of fenik shan you see her in that same armor
she's about the same age as grogu pretty close to
it so she'd probably be in her early 20s when this
series is happening but ming na will be playing
her character she was talking about it on her
twitter last week speaking of other mandalorian
easter eggs you notice those giant droids that
the bad batch is fighting in this trailer also
look exactly like the dark troopers from the dark
forces video game just painted white it should go
without saying that dave filoni is the showrunner
of the bad batch series in addition to all the
stuff he's doing with the other live action series
like the ahsoka series the mandalorian series
so you can kind of see their grand plan to set
up a lot of easter eggs and hints for things that
we'll see in the other live-action series that are
coming later in the timeline or that are happening
right now like on the mandalorian but there are
other tv shows that will debut in the next couple
of years that take place right after this as well
like the tentacle creature here that they're
escaping from looks very similar to the creature
from the mandalorian that ate grosgu in his pod
during season 2 episode 3. the mandalorians during
this period had just taken back the planet
mandalore from darth maul Bo Katan had become
regent right at the end of the clone wars after
they got rid of him in the shadow collective
but what happened during this period is that she
resisted imperial rule the emperor had her deposed
and replaced with gar saxon who became his new
puppet and if you remember all of darth maul's
former mandalorian super commandos the maul
deloreans that had the horns on their helmets
they became imperial super commandos basically the
same thing just serving at the will of the emperor
so we'll also see Bo Katan also probably ahsoka
show up during this series a little bit as well
too right now when this is happening ahsoka is
about 17 18 years old and she's gone on the run
she's in the outer rim hiding out for a hot minute
but eventually bail organa finds out where she
is and brings her into service of the rebellion
in its early days mando would be a couple years
younger than ahsoka but he's still a teenager in
training with the death watch the children of the
watch mandalorians during this period right when
this is happening after revenge of the sith he's
already taken his oath and put the helmet on
grogu would be in his early 20s so you have to
picture an even tinier version of grogu and this
is the beginning of the period he said where his
memory goes dark after the mystery person rescued
him from the jedi temple before anakin skywalker
killed all the other younglings in order 66
press f in the chat to pay respects for them
eventually they'll reveal who that mystery person
was on the mandalorian series but there are some
solid theories so far the reason his memory went
dark is most likely because whoever saved him used
the force ability to wipe out or block people's
memories and they just erase those events from
grogu's mind that's not a light side or a dark
side force ability necessarily any jedi can learn
to do it but it's very advanced so it wouldn't
have been any random jedi that could have done it
during the events of this show moff gideon is
still a young officer in the imperial security
bureau and thrawn hasn't quite become an admiral
yet but he's quickly rising through the imperial
ranks in the early days after the clone wars he
became an admiral faster than pretty much anybody
in the history of the empire you remember that we
have a couple mandalorian spin-off series that are
going to be set during the same time period coming
up in the next couple of years we have the ahsoka
series with rosario dawson's ahsoka and then we
have the rangers of the new republic series about
all the x-wing pilots all the characters from the
mandalorian and those other new series that they
introduce will cross over and eventually build
up to a big crossover event where grand admiral
thrawn will be the main villain but we'll see
grand admiral thrawn before that like a really
big epic battle in a couple years they haven't
said too much more about it than that they just
said that they will build up towards that event
also during this period darth maul escaped at the
end of the clone wars so right after revenge
of the sith he also goes into hiding and is
rebuilding his power base back up in the crimson
dawn crime syndicate so this series takes place
right before the events of jedi fallen order
which is about five years later calcestus finds
the jedi holocron with the names onto the other
jedi manages to save it from darth vader then
you have the events of solo a star wars story
where darth maul resurfaces then right after the
events of solo you have the events of the obi-wan
kenobi series where hayden christensen is coming
back to play darth vader and for anakin skywalker
flashbacks that's about 10 years after the events
of revenge of the sith then a couple years after
that you have the events of star wars rebels then
after that you have a new hope luke destroying the
death star at the battle of yavin then nine years
after that sort of skipping over the events of the
original trilogy mando finds grogu and you have
the beginning of the events of the mandalorian
series and then about a year after that during the
mandalorian season two we pick up with ahsoka tano
the events of her new live-action series will take
place during what's happening right now in the
mandalorian hopefully that kind of explains what's
going on i believe the bad batch episodes are
supposed to premiere sometime in the first half of
next year i think they'll be eight to ten episodes
in season one i don't know how many seasons
they plan on going maybe four to five seasons
there was a bunch more footage that dropped so
i might try to do one more trailer video before i
do my mandalorian season two finale video that'll
be friday so just make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any
of those episodes it's going to be really crazy
but there's so much awesome stuff coming up i'm
actually really excited about everything cannot
wait to say goodbye to the crap year that 2020
has been we're almost to 2021 you've almost made
it well you wait for everything click here for
that star wars trailer for the new obi-wan kenobi
series and click here for my brand new mandalorian
season 2 finale video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!